This is clearly a bus,
right?
No, no, not even close.
This is obviously a Greek people carrier
and if you want to get around recent
one of these,
better busts out your
electronic calculator and look
up the road knowledgey in a
quest machine.
But if that doesn't have your leg,
what would stick around?
And let's take a look at the weird,
the crazy.
And there's sometimes hilarious words
that tongues have for talking about new
tech knowledge
throughout India.
It's incredibly common for technical
terms to come from Sanskrit, not English.
In Sanskrit, you can learn all
about the principles of things,
the principles of chemistry,
the principles of prosperity,
even the principals of
pleasure. Uh, hello.
Where was that one in my
university's course catalog.
Never one to give into the barbarians.
China has crafted some nifty tech terms.
Take the two characters in mobile phone.
They stand for hand machine.
Clever enough. But check
out this word. Sure.
It's sounds like hacker,
but it cleverly slides past
copyright infringement. Hey,
we didn't steal it.
That's just our word for dark visitor.
If you come down with a fever
while speaking Swahili in Kenya,
you'll be a person sick
when you visit the doctor,
but let's hope you don't get diagnosed
with problem of kidney because then
they're probably going to have to shred or
Blake,
you
GE has made an art of ditching foreign
words and creating new Turkish ones since
the end of the Ottoman days.
Before you get too cozy.
Here we're talking about the
heyday of this kind of Ottoman,
not this kind of Ottoman.
For anyone out there who's to life goals
happen to be getting into space and
competing in the Turkish language
Olympiad. Yes, that's a thing.
Here's one stone for you to birds
practice Turkish in a space vehicle.
Totally makes sense,
right?
You'll then join the elite
group of spacemen era,
but you can't be totally averse to sharing
the experience with other languages
because you're going to need things like
rockets and computer algorithms to get
the,
speaking of computers in France and Spain,
it's an ordinator or is that or did nay
total or
I bet you wish your comp had a
name that powerful nearby Italy.
On the other hand has no problem just
using a computer, but to be honest,
not everyone in Italy is so
happy to take on new words.
The Vatican has good terms
for everything from audio,
visual fables to nocturnal
taverns to my personal favorite,
super spacious airships boom.
There it is.
A Latin jumbo jet,
you know,
I bet some Roman emperor has really wish
they had one of those collegial out.
We're looking at you. She's
just what history meet it,
right? Or Romans Soul plane.
If Latin jumbo jets can't convince you
that dead languages don't stay dead,
then check out Icelandic.
We're old resurrected words.
Dig themselves right out of
their Zombie Viking graves.
Yeah, it's cool that the old word
for line came in handy again,
but nothing beats booting
up your Icelandic number,
prophetess weighted go Iceland.
You're such a make believe land as if
we didn't already have proof of that in
the form of Bjork and Sigur Ros
cross the pond in the ink and Andy's,
you can take a class on the
world order in the native tongue.
In fact since patch already
means time or space,
why not dig into the
relations of world things?
Sorry you and this guy probably know that
better. It's the theory of relativity.
Got Your fill of physics.
Don't leave the new world just yet.
First drive north in your black
foot starts to run without a parent.
Cause if that's not fast enough,
the Koyukon of Alaska might suggest and
it rises of its own accord to get you
there a little faster.
If you don't have a term for it,
just make the word look.
Native Hawaii has this down Pat Hawaii
dicing words and phrases like I know Kia
gives a Halloween imports and authentic
look and feel and that gets us a come at
pula, assuming you don't want to go full
on native and call it in the electronic
brain. That is so cool. Getting
terms to sound and look more native,
even if they're totally not is everyday
business in Japanese with the locals can
box in for an examples by writing
them in a totally different script.
So hairdryers are hairdryers and roller
coasters are roller coasters in Japan.
Even if they don't look like it at first.
Yeah.
So see that and that and
that and that and that.
Yeah, they're all from
English. Oh, yeah. Hey,
there's one more piece of technology
I wanted to share with you guys.
It's called the subscribe button,
and if you just,
you and I can stick around for more
technology awesomeness in the future.
I promise not to do the robot ever
again. Just click it. Go ahead.
Yeah.